funny thing is that we gave or is 20
minutes to talk about all the innovation
you know I sit about 10 feet away it
used to be four feet away he's moving a
little bit farther away from but he
could actually talk all day I'm just in
a vision I trust me you and get bored
and and he was the one who sold me on
coming here because it was just that
belief of all the innovation that was
inside Google and they're going to point
that innovation can and that cloud like
like how can you not win and in process
of winning like you're redefining what
the instincts cloud is so so it's been
fantastic but on top of innovation
Google's really different in another way
as well and gcp is we're open right and
it's not by accident just that we
fundamentally believe that the cloud
that has the best features and the best
capabilities but that's built on open
technology and open api's just presents
the most valuable TI end users so that
really is is our mission and because of
that a lot of our innovation is just
happening externally because it just
advances so much faster and when you try
to do things in proprietary all you're
really doing is creating friction to
both adopt and impediments for people to
actually leave so to us this actually we
actually really internalize this and it
means you know really influences choices
that we make on a daily basis so at GC
peewee you know we're really trying not
to reinvent the wheel if a de facto API
already exists out there and we want to
have a similar service in gcp then we
adopt that API so the whole the whole
HBase you know ecosystem in technology
was created because of the big table
white paper by Google and so when we
actually took that internal service and
said we want to host it as the gcp
service instead of using that internal
API we put the open-source HBase APA on
it because it's just better for end
users to be able to adopt in the second
is if an open-source stack is already
out there and it has really great
adoption around it then you're going to
want to use it in the cloud as well you
shouldn't have to convert so actually
we've been bringing those in as managed
services you know and when we bring them
in as managed services is all this
amazing thing we can do in terms of
integrating them make it more reliable
you know integrating telemetry more
performant so you'll actually stay for
the value in that because the lock and
that's some of the things that we're
doing around redice my sequel
dupin spark the third is in open so she
can't draft you really got to get
involved in upstream if you really care
about technologies and you're building
your platform on it you can't just be
downstream and consume you've got to get
involved and that's what we've been
doing for years around around Linux and
now with dr. chef puppet I'm spinnaker
terraform and most recently cloud
foundry and then the last point around
this is that if there's technology that
doesn't exist out there but we really
feel like it needs to be part of cloud
you know you have a choice most people
just differentiate and build it
internally instead we've actually said
we're going to do that publicly and do
it openly and that's what we've been
doing around tensorflow we've been doing
around Cooper Nettie's apache beam you
know first Apache project I think that
was created by google which we think is
the future of MapReduce and grp see so
we know the model where it's open
innovation works right we've proven that
out the two of the most significant
intellectual property areas for Google
our machine learning and containers and
both of those we consciously chose to
develop them openly and now because of
that that we've looked at both Kubra
daddies and tensorflow and on github
those are now the number one and number
two most engage projects on alaga tub
and you know we just believe that
innovation doesn't have to be held for
proprietary advantages right kumaresan
tensorflow it's not a marketing stunt
they are both better technologies
because of that community involvement
upstream but it's not always about some
big massive on the source project even
the smallest of things can really get in
the way and impede adoption and so last
year you know right after I came here I
started talking to some you know
colleagues for the wall street banks and
what they really said is that they still
you know clouds not done there's all
these future things that they actually
need and what they want to do is now
that new google is serious they want to
start having more open conversations
about the advancement of the future
requirements right primarily these are
things around networking and security
and then how do you actually deploy
applications because the reality is what
they didn't want to do is have silo
conversations with each of the top three
cloud providers because then we all go
in and implement those things
differently right we're all going to do
them and it just it creates all this
gratuitous differentiation had to be
honest that's one of the things that's
plagued the whole entire I
t industry for many years and so it's
early days in the effort we actually
created working groups and leave or not
Google Azure and an AWS are all in the
same room with these top customers and
we're really trying to work it out and
have helping open dialogues so the one
nice thing about you know our commitment
to open means we actually get to work
with partners in a whole new way it's
much deeper you know often that looks
like partners actually just port their
products to gcp right and we're
answering you know help desk tickets and
when we really engaged on open and our
partners are open as well it actually
allows us to work with them uncoated so
it's really been a lot more fun and a
lot more productive so one of the
companies that recently actually formed
this type of relationship with is
pivotal and so pivotal doesn't need an
introduction but there you know the
corporate company behind cloud foundry
and Cloud Foundry is a platform as a
service and they've done a really good
job of helping people like really
convert to agile methodologies and cloud
native and they're having a lot of
successful on-premise and cloud so on
steam for queries here from pivotal he
runs engineering and I want to chat them
a little bit about a partnership
so we can stand or set the tone and
stand so I can't sit you'll get a
massive [ __ ] yeah so how did like the
relationship with pivotal and you know
and gcp get started sure so we had a you
know mutual customer come along and say
I really like pivotal cloud foundry and
the value that it gives me and I'm
really really liking gcp can I can I get
these two things together please and so
we started working together
co-developing on a solution to really
launch PCF on top of gcp and it's been
it's been just really really powerful
and now we're seeing growing demand for
it right and so that initial seed is
going to bear a lot of fruit so tell me
a little bit about two things one so
what's that collaboration felt like
working with our engineers a little too
what's the experience sort of new to gcp
yeah how does that fella so I mean it's
really blown our minds of the level of
collaboration J Marshall Eric Johnson
Evan Brown these folks came in well you
know San Francisco are the pivotal
office in San Francisco's just across
the street and you know we had these
folks from google show up sit down with
us pair with us you know working day in
and day out to to really perfect the
technology get it working and get it
deployed and it's just really I mean
incredible collaboration it sort of blew
my mind like we had to make some changes
to PCF we also had to make some changes
to gcp and they made those changes like
what it was it was really impressive and
then you know something something crazy
happened so we deployed PCF on top of
gcp and then one of my engineers came to
me and said he knocked on my office's
like unsee can I can I give a talk I'm
like sure you can give a talk what do
you want to give a talk about and he
said I want to give a talk about gcp i
was like huh and you know what happened
there was an aha moment right so here's
this engineer who's been working on you
other i as just for a while and he's had
this first experience with gcp and he
goes this is this is just so different
it's elegant it's thoughtful it's
performant it's stable performance table
are really important for us we have CI
pipelines that drive I as is really hard
like bring them to their knees and so if
they're flaky or if they're not up my
developers are not productive and and
and we just we saw this opportunity like
you know jump onto a platform that was
super productive and then I started to
dig into it a bit and you know the value
per dollar again just off the charts and
so you saw an opportunity to really sort
of pivot over and the the nice thing
about PCF is that for us and for our
customers you know we're cloud agnostic
you can run on AWS you can on Azure you
can on the gcp and so making that move
there's this is just very easy and so
you know we're now very eager customers
and we are internally a pivotal going to
be moving many of our workloads most of
our workloads over to gcp and we're just
really excited for where this that's
going to go yeah so what's next well
Lots is coming I don't have anything to
share today but in the next few weeks we
should have a lot of good news to share
with you all yeah awesome so i will say
that there's a lot of you know
assignments there's a lot of stuff that
needs to be done in engineering and not
all of it is fun and glamorous right
there's a lot of dirty work and and when
we actually started putting people on on
pillow and working on Cloud Foundry I
think there there's some of our happiest
most engaged engineers and they love
working with your it's just been fo it's
just been a really fun so that's been
great awesome awesome thank you
so the trends you know transition to
cloud for a born in the cloud developer
or a start-up is actually pretty simple
because they don't to go through a
transition at all but for most
businesses there you know you have a
large legacy of you know installed
applications infrastructures networking
administrative methodologies developers
and just institutional knowledge so what
I things that we actually think about at
GSP a lot is that what's that path to
adoption look like what can we actually
do so it doesn't look like you know this
separate thing and how do we actually
you know find what's creating the most
impedance you know in friction and get
and eliminate that so I want to talk a
little bit about that and the story goes
back eight years ago because the first
cloud service that google had was Google
App Engine right and as always talked
about it's an amazing service because
you can developers can publish these
services and they don't have to worry
about anything else they don't have to
worry about the reliability because we
take care of it you don't have to worry
about scaling up because we take care of
it scaling down we take care of all the
way back down to zero they aren't hiring
database administrators right and they
aren't dealing with any of the other
other underlying issues and like
managing OS upgrades it's a really
powerful platform and you and the end
result is you get this amazing service
at scale and your operational burden is
near zero but for some that jumped up as
is just a little bit of a bridge too far
and sometimes the easiest pattern for
the first part of cloud adoption is just
to have an API around you know a vm and
that really makes it much more easier to
consume because you're already doing
that inside of your data centers and
that was really the mind set on why even
though we had a pass is why we invested
in and then I as and why GCE came out
three years ago and obviously you know
you know now that seems right because
internally when we watch and we look at
the growth of our platforms we measure
it GCE is one of those services that we
actually measure with log scale right
just to watch the growth so I think
obviously it's really helping
enterprises a lot but we don't actually
see this as and you see a lot and the
world is like it's a silo like it's a
it's a platform as a service choice or
its emphasis or service choice it's
really not that way at all what we're
finding is people are coming to us
initially for GCE and what then they're
doing over times are adopting service by
service 40 ops you might start on VMS
and then you're you're start to use a
managed load balancer or you're using a
managed firewall or then you start to
use our auto scale
right or then you start to use our pass
for a database any type of database and
so you don't you never really made this
choice of what silo I meant you really
just found that easy is pattern to adopt
and then you actually grow into more of
a zero ops environment as you go and the
story is kind of similar for networking
when you think of like you know how
cloud originated it really was just a
separate subnet in the cloud all with
public eye facing IPS and now with gcp
we recognize that's not the right model
for enterprise right so what we've done
is now when you use gcp it looks much
more like private subnets in the cloud
all with private IPS you can easily
bridge those together you can easily put
a firewall in front of them and then
most importantly you can actually bridge
that network right into your on-premise
network without transiting over the
public internet so it feels far more
like clubs you've all to feel far more
like it's a data center extension on the
container side we talk a lot about that
because that's just you know our
language we Google grew up on containers
you know the developers inside of Google
don't really know about infrastructure
right they would be productive if they
did they're just publishing their code
in services on the board right and they
get everything else for free and that's
why google invested so much in NC groups
over a decade ago because C groups was
that technology inside a Linux that
allowed that isolation to happen right
so you get multiple containers on a
single Linux image and it doesn't
provide the security isolation but it
provides the needed resource isolation
and that was the first phase and now a
doctor the container movements at light
because on top of that linux kernel
isolation now you're getting is is
application confinement and application
portability right so it's really
powerful and so you actually can doctor
eyes applications containerized
applications and delirium across
multiple platforms multiple os's
multiple clouds that's really liberating
it's really if I had to compare it it's
really what VMware in Linux did long ago
by normalizing underwired hardware
platforms now Dockers bring that to a
whole new level and so you have to think
that you know five years time ten years
time you know transcoding VMs as a
method of migration or poor ability from
one vm format to another has to end so
this is really great for the IT industry
right but what it needed was a
management and orchestration system so
think about like how you imagine ASX in
your
environment today if you didn't have
either vsphere vcenter so because of
that contributing cougar Nettie's to
open source was just the obvious choice
for google because if we don't it'll
hold back the ubiquity of what this
container movement can be and then
second all these other different bespoke
solutions for managing containers will
arise and so you won't really get sort
of the standardization that you want
around management orchestration and so
kind of column it done right now like
cougar neighs has really become that de
facto management system for doctor and
you see that on github as the number one
most engaged project tensorflow is
second third was actually docker really
powerful trio and so this week actually
marks it was on Monday the release of
the open-source kuma is one dot for
milestone and you know hoping for a
great gke launch of the same tomorrow
actually and what what what the one nice
thing that Federation that one dot floor
brought was Federation been working on
it for a while pieces have been coming
out in the prior releases and what that
allows you to do is now with containers
allows you to have multiple clusters may
of containers i'll manage with a single
control plane and it's a really powerful
thing because these these clusters can
be on premise they can be in the cloud
and then nGCP that can be multiple zones
in the cloud so what you get out of that
is it makes it really simple for a
developer developer with one command can
publish a service a container based
service that's multihomed across
multiple clusters sitting behind a
single static IP address right and that
our global load balancer can route to
the route to the right cluster based on
latency you know based on capacity and
so you get this really powerful low
latency high-performance solution
without any extra operational costs and
this was a big thing like the I didn't
figure out what pokemon was till a
Friday night went Thunder made the call
that that there's the base that our QPS
was spiking and one of the tools that we
actually used it to help that out was
actually they used the one of the
earliest consumers of the Federation
capability getting multiple zones of gke
you're going to hear the whole story I
think this afternoon so I'm really proud
that all my source in Linux is
is a trusted enterprise platform you
know I spent almost 13 years at red have
is my personal mission and it was just
because I so believe in that UNIX
paradigm which became the Linux paradigm
and that you know that Intel like
commoditizing underlying Hardware
underneath made sense and that I had to
be open right but the on-ramp to cloud
is is bigger it's a heterogeneous
environment out there and it includes
more than Linux right includes windows
so Windows has really been a top
priority for gcp for for some time we
now have windows server 2008 we have
2012 we have 2016 I think it's coming in
october we have a full net stack we have
visual studio for developers we have
PowerShell support we have sequel server
images we have license portability that
Microsoft supports now and we have
dotnet client we build dotnet clients
across all of the gcp api's to make it
easier for developers so we really think
that you know this marriage of windows
with all the amazing things inside a gcp
like you know fast bootable custom vm
shapes and the fast network it really
all of a sudden means that gcp it you
know makes this awesome platform for
window shops so more in friction the
first adopters of cloud you know
naturally you know our aid of us users
and what we found though is that a lot
of 80 shooters come to gcp because of
the differentiation that oars was
talking about earlier you know these
faster VMs we have these shapes that you
don't have to be stuck to a set of you
know specified core sizes and specified
vm sizes you can actually pick an
arbitrary shape our sustained use
discounts because people believe it or
not don't love our eyes our private
global network you know no need to
schedule reboots because of live
migration in the bigquery analytics that
we talked about today that makes
redshift kind of look like a
departmental warehouse that you have to
manage yourself and so a few years back
when we're at saying we really need to
bring monitoring capability to gcp the
acquisition we made was a company
stackdriver that was running on AWS and
one of the choices that most companies
would make it say oh I'm going to move
that completely to gcp and then use that
for point of differentiation right
instead of we say we've got enough
differentiation for when users actually
using gcp but if it's going to be this
multi-cloud world isn't it a better
service for our users if we give them if
they're going to be using AWS as well
that they're going to have a single
monitoring alerting and logging back
plane that works across all and so it's
a lot it's a bigger investment on our
part but that's what we're committed to
do and so why I love the super quote I
mean one because it just it's a great
quote about stackdriver but even more
importantly to that it's what it says
what it signifies is that even in the
club world we're doing so much of the
managing of the infrastructure and the
managing of the services end users still
want to lemon tree right it's not like
make it all work and don't tell me how
you did it and so that's what we're
trying to give with stack drivers even
as we r you know you know orchestrating
services even when if you picked a
solution that's patching your OS you
still need to know that and so a big
part of stack driver is how do we
actually expose all the telemetry that's
happening inside the gcp so that it
makes sure that you have full awareness
so you know cloud you know has really
made infrastructure programmable you
don't file a helpdesk ticket to get a
server any longer you use an API right
and you also you know we've now made
everything programmatic firewalls
virtual machines networks you know the
network the you know any data store you
want so it's quickly becoming you know
foregone conclusion that infrastructure
is now programmable but really to like
really realize the dream the next phase
that has to extend into applications and
services and we're making progress to
you know that developers now packaging
their applications under containers is
super helpful for that because now
they're lightweight and they're portable
so they can be automated and then you
bring in Coober Nettie's so now you can
manage that without you can manage the
whole container environment without
managing underlying infrastructure so
the third phase that I'd say we're kinda
in and we haven't really figured out is
the industry yet is really how do you
actually you know represent micro
servers and services and then how do you
actually wire those together and deploy
those you know as an entity so there's a
lot of choices on how to do that we have
some there's a lot out there but they're
really the entry hasn't really
consolidated it on what that de facto
model for that is and so I think that's
the next phase and then unless you
unlock that then you really hold back a
lot of standardization and we move on to
solving the next problem so at gcp
obviously you know we have you is for
everything but we're putting everything
behind an API
so we're putting infrastructure behind
an API or putting all the services
behind API microservices right and
application stacks and so we really
think that you know cloud and gcp are
enabling the next generation of what an
ecosystem is going to look like and so
the reason I think about that is the
days of you know the selling of you know
binaries and software stacks right as a
commercial ecosystem you know it leaves
a lot to be desired right nobody likes
receiving stacks of software that they
have to configure etc etc book people
really want is what happens after that
like how to actually start to consume
capability through a service and through
an API and so we really think that's the
future of the commercial ecosystem are
really really at the very beginning part
of that journey is like how do we get
out of delivering stacks of software
even in the cloud because they're still
kind of doing that as well with the
ecosystem instead where you're doing use
provision capability from the API and
allow people to consume it and that's a
big reason why we acquired Apogee
because what we want to do is make it
easier for businesses to take their
services and enter that into that API
economy you know at the cloud providers
from an api perspective were already
there but there's so much value that
businesses can have and if they can
bring their services into this new
ecosystem an apogee is so far ahead and
figuring out a lot of us you know their
api management deals with all aspects of
authorization and security it deals with
d das it deals with integration it deals
with quota deals with billing it deals
with you know specifying an SLA and
those are all the facilities that you
need if you really want to enter this
business to business api economy and so
gcp users are actually going to be able
to now when there's a PG powered
services they can actually integrate
them whether those services are running
out another cloud or whether they're
running out in premise and then likewise
builders that are actually building on
gcp are going to be able to use that
whole apogee framework and they're going
to easily be able to publish their
services through the apogee api's right
to meet whole whole new markets so as
you might expect you know Apogee and gcp
you know have a lot of common customers
it's not really that surprising so I
actually want to introduce you to one of
those customers today so please welcome
devine Krishna of the home
right so um tell us you know home
depot's really making us digital
transformation right so tell us what
that's like and what that mission is all
about yeah you know for us it's it's all
about connecting our stores to our
digital properties and providing our
customers a fantastic experience in
their home improvement that's what
digital transformation for us means and
we call it interconnected retail
internally within our company and from a
customer standpoint it's all about
making it easy for them to research and
now the problem they're trying to solve
research the products by the products
wherever they want to bite get it
delivered when they want to get it
delivered whether it's picking up in the
store or delivery to the house or get it
delivered same day that's really from a
customer standpoint oh so how does API
is an apogee fit into all that yeah and
we've been using apogee for it for a few
years now you know are you look at our
interconnected solution platforms
they're pretty much all based on
microservices architecture and it's both
services that are internal facing and
services that are external in the
customer and third-party facing and when
you think about the scale of what we run
its its near impossible to manage it
through people and manual processes and
so that's where something like an API
gateway comes into play and right now we
use it really for external that's
because you know we have this hybrid
model of something's running into you
know in our data centers and something's
running in the cloud and the more we
move the cloud it makes it reduces the
latency and it's creates a you know
better case for leveraging something
like in
so you're an apogee user but I hear
you're also a DCP user so how are you
using gcp today yeah i mean we're early
stages gcp is one of our cloud
infrastructure solutions early stages
been using gcp for about 18 months now
being now you know very good so far it's
one the scale of what you know Google
runs on so getting that sort of scale of
infrastructure is you know awesome and
then also some of the offerings that
come out things like stackdriver that he
just talked about you know we are we
tend to like to want to be an early
adopter and try things out many things
work well some things don't work as well
but overall extremely pleased with how
it's going awesome so funny story goes
back a few years but when I was actually
had to pick what I want to go to college
for I want to be a carpenter right and
my gowns counselor said no right and so
I had no other interest so I did
computer science and so I have to admit
I'm a little bit jealous that you
combine both of these fields together so
we in a inner palo alto store we have an
opening for a cam i have a cow
so it is absolutely very compelling we
think this is actually going to be the
spark of the next journey to really
create an API economy for just better
business to business and so we're not
going to create a pudgy as a proprietary
silo we're actually looking like how do
we actually integrate that as we retool
that into every all of our current so
you made around open source so you'll be
seeing a lot more around microservices
and api's and end points you know
emerging an open source and out of the
Cougar Nettie's efforts because when you
think about it it's actually five worlds
converging it's the cloud it's open
source it's containers it's these micro
services that are building out of the Ku
Bonetti stack and its commercial api's
so you know today like I mean it's it's
all around open it's all around
innovation it's all on how do we
actually work in a more frictionless way
with our partners like have it in our
customers like how do we figure those
things out and make it easier to adopt
cloud and how do we actually build this
new commercial ecosystem so the past
years have been really exciting and I
actually think the next few years are
going to be even more exciting so thank
you for that